yeah okay welcome to new video in the
repertoire series this time I'll talk
about the Dutch defense d4 f5 um yeah it
took quite a long look at at this I have
tried to quite some some varied slides
myself there um I was tempted to
recommend some sideline but at the end I
yeah I'm going to recommend this just
some just the main lines but it's it's
really difficult to to look at these in
detail as it is really complicated
um one thing I'd like to suggest if you
are an active aggressive player and you
like to look at some sharp lines before
the game and then try them out um it's
actually the very old Stormin gambit
with e4 and it's quite interesting that
says that's especially one line this is
which is tricky um here now I have six
of course the main move on you time and
time again in blitz games you get this
one and just pick up the pawn in the
game so it has got some some easy tricks
also no Bishop g5 and here by far the
main move for black I think also the
best one is 96 d5 95 and then Queen e2
which is really a tricky line um I won't
show it in detail because it's it's
really um yeah very tactical and
uncomplicated but I think it's an
interesting way to play I think you
shouldn't just play this without any
preparation at home but if you take a
look at this a little bit more closely
then I think it could be a very
dangerous weapon um
especially for games with the shorter
time control as blacks kings often a
problem here um yeah um this has become
also somewhat popular it was really rare
line a couple of years ago I remember
that I looked at this really I don't
know five six seven years ago when I
just had and I know it doesn't games or
something and I I did to refresh just
today and found that it was played on a
150 times or so by now so it is really
has gotten um it's gotten some
popularity going for it so it's it's
interesting um but I think at the end of
the day it's it's still the main line
that I should recommend this is so
honest just three three and of course
black has some various setups here
within the Dutch I think they are mostly
a three setups you can talk of this is
some one is the Leningrad variation was
g6 um the Stonewall was easy six and t5
and the classical - woozi six and d6 um
let's start with the Stonewall I think I
have 6 g - e 6 and then see for what
what's important here is that you don't
play Knight f3 too early because you can
do that but the particular idea I have
against the Stonewall one I have I've
picked from the lines it's not my
original idea of course is to to place a
knight on h3 um this would run something
like this d5 983 c6 castles Bishop d6
you should f4 this is the idea of the
night placement that if black should
take here you can very nicely recapture
with the night iam um black now most
often just retreats the night
the bishop in order to white the
exchange and then very often play
continues like ninety two castles Queens
to in general I would recommend not to
study too much of concrete lines here
the Stonewall is really a purely
strategical opening so it's a good idea
to to look at at some games here or just
pick out a games of high rated players
and to check how they handle disposition
on on the white side I think it's better
than to just look at concrete move
citizens you need to get some ideas how
to how to play them especially when it
comes to piece placement very often a
good way to place the pieces tonight
this Knight to f3 and this night will
often try to go to d3 and on d3 and
every the Knights have got the best
positions here as they cover all the the
dark squares like C 555 g5 you need to
really study some games an interesting
point here if black plays not d5
immediately but starts with c6 which is
a clever move order you shouldn't play
Knight h3 because black still has got
the option to go for a d6 + e5 setup and
then the knight would be quite silly on
h3 it's important to know that you start
with this tricky move just the waiting
move which is useful useful in much
cases and now black needs to commit
somehow and usually he just returns to
the stone wall here with d5 as he
doesn't want to place the bishop on this
rather passive Square and now these six
can be just answered
with 9024 so this is useful move to
remember this position of course can
also easily arise from d 4e 6 c 4 F 5
the default is 64 if I move order yeah
that's it for the Stonewall really um
just as I mentioned in order to fight
the stone ball correctly you really need
to study some games and I cannot show a
couple of games here so pick out mu spy
games by good players and try to figure
out how they handle this position um
another alternative here of course to d5
is just Bishop e7 Bishop f3 castles
cancels d6 the so-called classical Dutch
which is I think more dangerous than it
it looks at first sight my
recommendation here would be to go for
could be form this is I think an
interesting way to play the main line of
course once Knight c3 Queeny a droopy
one and then a four which is very
complicated I don't want to go into all
this technical stuff here a one
interesting way as mentioned this before
the idea is for instance na deform
Bishop me too we should have six 9bd to
to get some room space here on the Queen
side and if black plays for instance
knight c6 you have always the option to
attack it directly with b5 and send it
to some less active square I think this
is a good way to handle this position
with before which also white some lots
of really sharp lines that at first side
this position of blacks looks rather
passive but it can it can be deceptive
it can be very active and
this is a good idea to to avoid the main
lines my black maybe has got more
knowledge then then we have of course
this variation has not played that often
but the most common way of playing the
Dutch nowadays is of course the setup
was g6 leningrad variation I recommend
93 Bishop g7 castles castles d6 of
course White's move before me before d6
we should be 2 c6c for this kind of
setup of course black can also play d6
and Queenie a door maybe play quick h6
and g5 and so on black has some some
some other moves you can play but in
general I also recommend the setup which
is rather similar to the to the
classical Dutch if you compare this
position to the classical - position we
had the knight on e4 in the final
position and black shuffled the bishop
from east 7 to f6 and this is somewhat
similar like also might play 94 at some
point and he's got the bishop on a long
diagonal in general this before Bishop
b2 b2 setup makes it harder for black to
achieve the desired moves on 75 and
white has said yes to expand on the
Queen side but also I'm still breaking
in the center with e4 at at the
appropriate moment just similar to two
other - lines I recommend to pick up
some some games and check how high rated
players play this opening I think it's a
it's a good idea here especially um in
general it is a bit
difficult to learn the lines here of
let's say move by move as legs position
as some yeah somewhat slippery you can
play all kinds of moves let's say Queen
eight here or night a six or King edge
aid or age six and so on and it doesn't
make any sense to to look at specific
moves they're just I have look how the
games develop if good players play this
I think on a grand master level they're
basically two lines now played against
the Dutch which is the main line was
Knight c3 which I didn't recommend here
it's also fine of course this is is this
line here on and the the thing I am the
the line I am showed you with before
this has the two main tries against the
the leningrad touch so what it's easy to
find hundreds of games and just filter
and to check out how the highest-rated
players a handle to position now the
Dutch can be a tricky opening to face
and also one opening where often on
white fields provoked to to show
something special on or to punish black
because f5 is supposed to be yeah maybe
a risky move or something but yeah it's
also an ambitious move and player some
who opted for this often I think handle
the kind of unconventional positions
rather well so you are
I think should prepare yourself with
studying some some example games to do
not be surprised what kind of I want to
play like my to come up with um yeah I
think I think we are we're through with
the Dutch and yeah
that or a dress that's one line actually
I didn't I didn't mention just in this
move order of course besides the things
I already have shown ups I'm like also
can give the check here and this is also
interesting I actually recommend to to
play it simply also with Bishop d2 moves
like Knight c3 don't really fit into
this position the combination of the
bishop on g2 and the knight on c3 very
often doesn't yeah does it really work
well together just this move should be
fine um you need to be aware that if
black captures here um which which piece
you are now now take with very often it
is it's better to to capture with the
Queen in order to get a more active
placement off the Knights on f3 and c3
so um let's say castles Nazis 356 and
then white might even go for a quickie
for here in general I'm the bishop the
phone line is playable but it's it's not
so ambitious but okay still you can you
can face it of course yeah I think
that's it some for the Dutch defense and
I think I'm almost through with all the
openings the next video will deal with I
think yeah really the odds and ends that
that are still there okay thanks for
watching and make sure to catch the last
video as well